a Russian opposition activist and
prominent Kremlin critic has been
sentenced to 25 years in prison by a
court in Moscow Vladimir karamorza was
convicted of treason and denigrating the
military he was arrested a year ago
after he denounced Russian President
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine
Kara morza called Putin's government a
dictatorship and he says he has survived
two poisonings which he blamed on the
Kremlin while Alexander solovyov is a
Russian opposition politician himself he
joins us from Limassol in Cyprus your
reaction to this sentencing 25 years in
prison
well uh uh first of all of course that
is absolutely a stalin-like term so uh I
mean recently uh the authorities used to
uh sentence opposition figures for like
five seven years which is already a lot
I mean despite the stereotype that five
years is like something something okay
it is not but now this new kind of uh uh
repressions are starting I'm afraid that
the usage of the state treason article
is going to uh to to to get higher and
higher and uh of course
got this uh sentence uh just because
he's been uh fighting corruption uh
since I don't know since the very
beginning of Putin's era and he went
mostly because he's one of the authors
and uh one of the main figures to to
push and to Lobby the uh the magnitude
act the First Act of
um personal sanctions imposed on Russian
authorities uh involved directly
involved in uh in killing uh Sergey
magnitsky the lawyer who investigated uh
enormous frauds and Corruption within
the Russian system and who was later
killed in prison for that
okay Mr solavio if you're saying you're
explaining to this that even by Russian
standards a 25-year prison sentence is a
very heavy sentence why do you think
that is what what lessons should we be
learning from that
well first of all that's just an attempt
of sending signal to to the rest of the
opposition figures to leave Russia
immediately they didn't uh do that by by
now uh that if somebody stays they will
face the same uh same consequences
is it still possible to criticize the
president or the war in Ukraine in
Russia
well uh it's just uh the the reason for
uh initiating this criminal case was uh
the fact that he uh Vladimir was uh
criticizing the war he was strictly
opposing the war in Ukraine but then
when the criminal case has already been
initiated They just added and added and
added more more episodes so uh they they
basically they don't care whom do you
criticize president or war or corruption
it's just if they start uh suppressing
you they will probably not stop they
will they won't stop continue I mean
continuing are there still voices of
dissent within Russia
uh yeah there are still a few but uh
they have to be extremely cautious most
of them are already either under house
arrest or under pre-trial restriction or
already in uh in prison uh so um and
most of uh most of us uh has already
either left or uh imprisoned back in
Russia so those few who are still left
today well basically
uh they could be put into jail for for
saying literally anything
so for instance you're an opposition
politician you you you're in Cyprus as
we said uh in the introduction do you
feel it would be possible for you to go
back to Russia
uh well I hope so uh but
um I'm not sure that uh that that would
be immediately that would immediately be
possible when I did not know what
Vladimir Putin does
uh being realistic I should admit that
even uh When Vladimir Putin dies uh the
system will probably have uh the the the
period of a year or two uh this
turbulence is this uh uh the the most uh
dangerous period uh so
um I'm absolutely sure that all of us
would sooner or later be possible to
come back but
um I don't think it's gonna be it's it's
gonna be easy
Alexander solovyov thank you for joining
us on the program today
thank you